[Musique]
sylvia seuil de soutanes bonjour bonjour
bonjour à tous les intérieurs auditrice
de matière la première même si
globalement la rentrée scolaire s'est
plutôt bien passé il est vrai que des
rares qu'il n'y ait pas quelques quoique
dans ce type d'exercice
ça a été le cas pour cette rentrée
scolaire 2018 2019 avec notamment une
grève de plusieurs jours qui a touché le
lycée professionnel agricole du robert
l'on comprend pas très bien ce qui a pu
se passer s'il vient de saïd soutien
parce qu'il ya un peu plus d'un an en
août 2017
vous aviez fait vous conseillère
exécutive à la ctm en charge de
l'éducation un état des lieux des
installations prise en charge par la ctm
vous étiez allé à ce lycée du robert ce
lycée professionnel agricole vous avez
visité la salle de microbiologie et le
proviseur de ce lycée indiquait qu'il y
avait une écoute très attentive au
niveau de la ctm et pour vous vous
indiquez aussi ce qui compte c'est que
les élèves travaillent dans de bonnes
conditions et puis patatras à cette
rentrée il ya eu une grève enseignants
certains enseignants et des élèves qui
réclament davantage de moyens
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans ce laps
de temps alors le poème du lycée l'e42
du robert est un peu complexe parce
qu'on a un lycée qui est adossé à un
self ppa et donc on a un budget commun
est en fait le choix du conseil
d'administration soit ça a été voté en
conseil d administration c'était de
faire des travaux au cfppa du lorrain
mais malheureusement avec les fonds
dévolus au lycée enfin entre autres et
ce qui fait les prêts les professeurs
que j'ai rencontré citons mon retour en
martinique lundi en quinze monts
exprimer le fait l'impression que vous
êtes venus éteindre l'incendié
ma politique qui n'était pas sur place
donc ma politique c'est toujours de
répondre quand il ya une difficulté je
vais au front je n'ai pas peur de ça
c'est pas la grecque il me fait venir
mais simplement quand ya une difficulté
je viens et donc ce problème là fait que
nous avions des professeurs qui étaient
un peu perdus parce que la réponse était
de dire qu'on n'avait pas d'argent car
les projets pédagogiques pour mener les
projets pédagogiques
donc la réponse que j'ai fait pour
apaiser un peu la situation même si même
si c'est quand même un peu compliqué
c'est de dire que les projets des
professeurs du les plages et du robert
serait suivie avec un fléchage des deux
l'argent c'est à dire que le projet
serait accepté au niveau de la septième
avec un fléchage direct sur le projet
pour que le projet soit accompagné
financièrement
voilà concernant la cuisine pédagogique
là je reconnais que nous avions pris du
retard puisque on avait prévu pack 2018
et en fait on s'est rendu compte qu'on a
pris du retard à cause des appels
d'offres qui était infructueux enfin on
connaît toute cette démarche là mais en
tout état de cause et les travaux ont
bien démarré parce qu'on espère livrer
la cuisine au courant du mois de
novembre
donc ça c'est une réponse à apporter là
où j'étais un peu surpris c'était la
demande des élèves qui demandaient plus
de toilettes parce qu'il y avait deux ou
trois toilettes à leur disposition bon
au moins on est en fait du tout je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait beaucoup
plus que nous avions refait à neuf
alors peut-être que ça ne s'est pas vu
dans les reportages mais que nous avons
refait à neuf lui de six toilettes et
que donc c'est depuis ce une
organisation interne d'ouvrir certains
toilettes certains espaces parce qu'au
niveau du cfppa nous avons un bâtiment
neuf avec des twilight 9 peut-être de
réfléchir à une réflexion au niveau de
l'établissement
voilà ce que je peux dire ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que monsieur le
proviseur effectivement nous avez
adressé un courrier au niveau de la ctm
le 2 octobre pour nous remercier pour
tous les travaux que nous avions initiée
dans cet établissement et pour demander
de poursuivre bien sûr le travail ce que
nous faisons de toute façon avec ses
équipes d'azoté angleterre manque de
moyens ne correspond pas ils n'ont pas
de réalité voilà le lycée est
excédentaire lycée lui-même la partie
lycée est excédentaire simplement comme
c'est un fonds fongible on peut utiliser
l'argent pour ces faits vaste que j'ai
proposé c'est de faire en sorte que le
solef ppa puisse être vraiment source de
revenus pour que le sait fut là soient
autonomes
aujourd'hui l'argent du lycée est
utilisé pour le cfp opère donc c'est là
où bon c'est un choix du conseil
d'administration je respecte le fait
flipper c'est le sens et de formation
pour les apprentis voilà ce mot là ce
serait adossé au lycée adolphe chérioux
douala c'est ça donc c'est ça que je
vais expliquer simplement bon de ne pas
eiffage pense qu'il est important de ne
pas semer la confusion et de trouver des
solutions c'est ce qui compte le plus
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
répondu favorablement aux demandes qui
ont été faites mais je demande vraiment
à cet établissement de réfléchir aux
sources de financement
par exemple la taxe professionnelle sur
le robert doit pouvoir être actionnés
pour accompagner ce lycée
là la rentrée de certains établissements
scolaires a été perturbée aussi par la
grève de personnels enfin issus du fait
que des contrats n'ont pas été
renouvelés pour un certain nombre de
personnels à la ctm et particulièrement
des ce qu'on appelait avant les atos
confins des agents techniques qui opère
donc dans des établissements scolaires
ça continue alors le dialogue a l'air de
se nouer
peu à peu avec francis carole vous même
vous avez à votre tour vous avez aussi
vous êtes impliqué dans cela est ce que
vous espérez une issue rapide
oui alors effectivement pour ratisser
territoriaux éditrice ce sont des
contrats à durée déterminée
oui donc un début et une fin on peut
comprendre que ces personnes qui ont
envie de de continuer à s'impliquer dans
la vie parce que je pense que j'ai des
personnes qui ont pris des engagements
qui ont des enfants qui font des études
qu'ils font quand une vie quoi et en
fait ce que je voudrais également dire
c'est que dans le choix de monsieur le
président cela était aussi de donner la
chance à d'autres personnes et ces
autres personnes elle nous remercient
tous les jours parce qu'elle était elle
aussi au chômage et elles ont aussi des
enfants qui font du travail est alors
aujourd'hui on est passé de 42 à 30 mai
ce qui a motivé la grève c'est peut-être
aussi la méthode et mouvement mardi
je n'en disconviens pas c'était à brut
c'est ça je reconnais que c'était à brut
et c'est justement la concertation qui
fait que président à la dernière réunion
ce que j étais présent a indiqué que
lorsqu'il y aura des remplacements
on ferait appel à ses personnels là
c'est ce qui ad'ailleurs été fait pour
quelques-uns séjour gagner maintenant
moi ce que je veux c'est que vraiment au
niveau des emplois de la collectivité
je pense que c'est important d'en parler
au niveau des ressources humaines il
faut que les mutations se sont faites en
interne qu'on puisse pérenniser certains
postes quand il ya vraiment besoin
et puis qu'on le fasse de moins en moins
appel en fait à ces contrats qui sont
des contrats précaires pour moi je ne
pense pas que ce soit de bonnes choses
et ça ne participe à la transparence de
de la vie de la cité m
alors cette rentrée a été
malheureusement très malheureusement
même marqué par le décès d'un enfant qui
avait dans un bus s'en souvient c'était
au début de la rentrée
à la suite de ce drame le se-unsa et
puis également le snuipp de martinique
le snuipp fsu
comment dirais-je ont fait des
communiqués demandant plus de moyens là
encore pour un dispositif d'accueil de
sécurité avec une plus grande vigilance
notamment concernant les écoles
maternelles la prise en main des élèves
vous même vous avez été directrice
d'établissement scolaire donc ça doit
vous toucher particulièrement
qu'est ce que vous en dites c'est bien
celle qui était non seulement j'ai été
directrice d'école mais j'étais aussi
élue aux affaires scolaires de la ville
de rivière famille et lorsqu'on a fermé
l'école de là haut il y avait un il y
avait un ramassage scolaire des élèves
qui allaient au bourg des élèves
d'écoles maternelles lorsqu'on a
également l'un problème au niveau de
l'école de des marinières on a acheminé
les élèves de l'école des marinières
verte au rail des élèves d'écoles
maternelles et moi je pense que monsieur
le maire de la ville de rivière salée a
pris la bonne décision c'est à dire de
faire en sorte que dans les bûches
obligatoirement un personnel soit
présent un personnel d'accompagnement
d'encadrement soit présent dans les bus
pour pouvoir justement éviter ce genre
d'écueil là parce que enfin moi j'ai
entendu un petit loïs politique et la
muscade même fourni ce qui a changé
un agent qui était d'ailleurs un agent
des écoles 1 qui est déjà dans
l'encadrement des écoles mais sur son
planning
il était prévu qu'il puisse qu'elle
puisse être présente dans le bus
accompagner les enfants et des cendres
est tous les enfants et je pense que ça
c'est déjà une première piste
alors on va me dire que les communes
n'ont pas d'argent mais je pense que à
ce prix là on peut on peut en tout cas
réfléchir bien bien plus parce que j'ai
entendu aussi le fait qu' il faudrait
que les peuples et les directeurs et
directrices appelle les parents mais je
pense qu'on ne se rend pas prévenu
immédiatement les parements sur les 1
100 concessionnaires pas bien compte de
la complexité d'une vie d'un termine
d'une directrice d'école qui parfois une
classe et donc de prendre le temps
d'appeler une dizaine de parents de
tomber sur leur messagerie de s'assurer
que l'enfant élève je pense que lass
c'est pas la bonne solution à mon avis
moi qui suis en tout cas quelqu'un du
terrain je vois pas que ce la bonne
solution
sauf si on met une personne
dévolue à ça le matin et qui ne fait que
ça le matin et qui appelle qui rappelle
les parents parce que souvent les appels
ne passe pas parce que le réseau n'est
pas il ya quand même des mesures à
apporter sur wii où il faut un enfant
d'école maternelle doit forcément il
doit forcément avoir un personnel autre
que le chauffeur le chauffeur il a fait
sa route il faut que je fasse attention
à sa route c'est pas le chauffeur à mon
avis qui doit avoir cette ce regard là
bas c'est presque la fin il nous reste à
peine une minute si de versailles sous
ten le le climat politique globale vous
vous disiez il ya pas longtemps dans une
interview la en juillet dernier juillet
2018 j'ai retrouvé sa dent donc dans le
france antilles et en titre nous n'avons
pas les moyens de notre politique
tout à fait nous nous tous et où tout le
monde confondues tous les élus de grands
ensembles et pour ma payant chance
effectivement nous avons envie de
réaliser beaucoup de choses pour la
martinique
moi par exemple j'ai toujours dit il me
faudrait le double de l' enveloppe qui
est dévolue aux travaux n'en existe dans
les collèges et lycées
aujourd'hui alors moi je suis pas
quelqu'un qui reste sur les mêmes
positions ce qui a été écrit là je le
pensais encore mais aujourd'hui je me
bats pour trouver des solutions avec
monsieur le préfet et monsieur le
recteur on travaille sur le contrat
convergent un score dont vous arrêtez
pas c'est le constat fait exactement
moi je suis une force de proposition
région cherche toujours de par exemple
on a mobilisé les fonds ainsi qui
permettent d'avoir une sécurisation et
le niveau des établissements scolaires
mais une forme d'aboutissement pour la
prévention de la délinquance des coûts
et donc ses trente quatre mille euros
c'est pas beaucoup mais au moins ce
fonds là on l'a complètement de tunisie
mais aujourd'hui je peux être force de
proposition avec monsieur le recteur
pour travailler sur d'avoir des
enveloppes supplémentaires sur le
numérique sur le para sismiques
surtout ces fonds la clé nous manque et
qu'il faut vraiment développe ce manque
de moyens ils émanent de vivien de quoi
de l'état 2
bien sûr bce du président du conseil
exécutif qui tient trolls et les cordes
de la bourse
enfin je pense d'eux c'est à partir
d'une bonne gestion que de vouloir faire
en sorte que nous dès que nous nous
éloignons de la lande l'endettement que
nous avions au niveau de deux là du
début de la septième
mais malgré tout effectivement l'état on
voit bien qu'à les moyens sont
insuffisants
nous avons par exemple des de l'argent
qui devrait entrer pour le social plus
de 300 millions d'euros qui sont dans
les qui manquent dans les caisses
aujourd'hui donc oui c'est un constat
partagé mais on a des solutions il faut
de l'imagination on va y arriver
vous êtes toujours battante on s'en rend
compte mais toujours merci sylvia saïd
soutane bonne journée et bon week-end à
tous le monde vous retrouvez jimmy mai